♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE PAUL RYAN ANNOUNCED THAT
HE WOULDN'T BE RUNNING FOR
REELECTION.
HE HAS BEEN SPEAKER FOR ALMOST
THREE YEARS AND HE LEAVES BEHIND
A PARTY IN SHAMBLES.
REPUBLICANS ARE ON TRACK TO LOSE
THE HOUSE THIS FALL FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN TEN YEARS.
RYAN DESERVES A LOT OF THE BLAME
FOR THAT.
DONALD TRUMP WON UNEXPECTED LIEN
2016 BY VALLEY TO SECURE THE
BORDERS AND FOCUS ON THIS
COUNTRIES VANISHING MIDDLE
CLASS.
RYAN ACTED LIKE NONE OF THAT
EVER HAPPENED.
HE NEVER LIKED TRUMP PERSONALLY
AND THAT'S FINE.
BUT HE IGNORED VOTERS, THAT'S
ALL FINE.
HE CONSIDERED DEMOCRACY AND
INCONVENIENCE, DELIVERED A
MASSIVE CORPORATE TAX CUT.
BLOCKED MEANINGFUL BORDER
SECURITY.
MOST REPUBLICANS DON'T AGREE
WITH PAUL RYAN, SO NO WONDER THE
PARTY IS COLLAPSING.
RYAN IS FLEEING THE SCENE OF THE
CRIME.
HE IS ONLY 48 AND WILL SOON BE